trend how are you today hi great how are
you doing
i'm doing fantastic i i really enjoyed
hawkeye i want to say thank you for
bringing kate bishop on screen but i
think more importantly thank you for me
for bringing lucky the pizza dog on
screen because i've
been waiting for that and he's right
there eating some pizza and i love it so
thanks so much awesome
so you've been with marvel studios for a
very long time correct me if i'm wrong
but you've worked on everything since
iron man correct yeah i actually started
someone should perform i started at
marvel about 14 years ago when iron man
and hulk came out so um wow amazing to
see where we were
then and where we are now
oh it's fantastic i did a re-watch not
too long ago and it is it's truly
incredible to see it so i'm curious as
somebody who's been with marvel from the
start you personally why did you think
it was time for hawkeye to get his own
show to get his spotlight
in the mcu
well because you know steve rogers i've
had many uh multiple stories told tony
stark thor
so all of the other avengers have had
sort of their
time on stage um and it made sense that
it was about time that we tell the clint
barton story um and and dive deeper into
you know who he is um and and sure we've
shown um some of that you know with his
family
in ultron and and and the loss that he
faced during you know endgame but
there's still so much more to explore
with him and i think that was one of the
reason why i gravitated towards this
particular um project is that um
the door is wide open in terms of who he
is in the past and who he is you know
now so
that's and bringing kate bishop into the
world is is also an amazing thing it is
well that was that was actually another
question i had for you i i love that
it's time for hawkeye to get his
spotlight and i think a lot of people
are gonna say the same thing i think a
lot of people are really excited but
when decided upon the hawkeye series um
a lot of this seems to be based off of
matt fractions run in the comics how did
this how did the decision come about to
implement kate bishop into the series
well i couldn't stop putting down the
comics when i was reading it i just
absolutely love awesome this tone the
style the story and most importantly
clint and kate bickering and bantering
in that run um i think that was what was
the most appealing part of um uh of
fraction was that he created this
dynamic between the two of them that you
know one minute they're arguing then the
next minute they're getting along or
they're joking and and so i think that
was what was fun about it and also
putting clint you know obviously the
clint barton that we have created over
the decade is is um
different from the fraction run and i
wanted to inject a little bit of that
light-hearted um feel of the clint
barton in this version and what better
way to do it than to bring kate bishop
and pull that out of him a little bit
right and i think it actually did a
fantastic job with that i i did kind of
like the light-hearted feel to it i
liked the christmasy feel to it that was
uh that was really cool in my opinion
are we witnessing you know the birth of
a new young avenger here with uh kate
bishop
i mean look i think our we take it one
step at a time and you know we want to
make sure we get k bishop right
and you know i think that's the most
important thing um and um and i think
haley really brings that to life and you
know we'll we'll see what happens down
the line
well i think she did an incredible job i
would love to see her as a young avenger
um kevin feige has mentioned in the past
specifically when it comes to
actors like jake gyllenhaal that he
meets with them
about several projects about several
different characters before they
actually come to the conclusion that
this is the character that you should
play was there any other roles that
haley steinfeld was
maybe just
thought that could be right for her or
was it always just kate bishop anytime
that there's a character that we're you
know wanting to cast we throw out names
here and there and see what fits but
with haley
um what's interesting is as soon as she
walked into the room to meet with um
kevin and me it was it was we just knew
that she was kate bishop just the way
she just you know carried herself um
you know we have a vision of who kate is
in our mind and as soon as we saw her it
was just like this is the person um
there's there's
kevin you know obviously we got up shook
her hand and kevin's like do you want to
be a part of the mcu that's how strongly
we felt about haley and you know it
she
she did an incredible job uh
bringing kate to life for us wow so
after the first meeting it was the
handshake you're in you're in wow and i
think i see why after watching the first
couple of episodes uh she is fantastic
the show's great i can't wait to watch
the rest of it trent thank you so much
for your time greatly appreciate it it's
great chatting with you absolutely take
care